PROVIDE NON-POTABLE WATER AND
POTABLE WATER TO OUR RESIDENTS.
WE WANT TO THANK THE MANY
VOLUNTEERS WHO HAVE HELPED WITH
THAT EFFORT.
>> WHERE DOES THE FAULT LIE FOR
THIS GETTING TO THIS POINT?
>> WELL, THIS IS THE
ACCUMULATION OF YEARS AND YEARS
OF ACCUMULATED PROBLEMS,
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
LIFTING UP FOR THE BETTER PART
OF, YOU KNOW, THREE TO FOUR
YEARS.
YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN SAYING THAT
IT IS NOT A MATTER OF IF OUR
SYSTEM WOULD FAIL, BUT WHEN OUR
SYSTEM WOULD FAIL.
I CAN REMEMBER AS FAR BACK AS
1988 WHEN MY FAMILY MOVED TO
JACKSON AND THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAD WITH OUR WATER SYSTEM AT
THAT TIME.
AND SO IT HAS BEEN AN
UNDERINVESTMENT INTO THE SYSTEM.
AND I THINK THAT THERE IS, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS, YOU KNOW, A
LITTLE BIT TO BE SHARED ACROSS
THE BOARD THROUGH LEADERSHIP ON
EVERY LEVEL.
AND SO WE HAVE TO HAVE A UNIFIED
FRONT THAT WE'RE GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THESE
CHALLENGES ARE MET.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN GOING IT
ALONE.
WE HAVE BEEN INVESTING EVERY
DOLLAR WE HAVE, NOT ONLY, YOU
KNOW, AS RECENTLY AS AN $8
MILLION PIPE ALONE TO BETTER
SERVE SOUTH JACKSON, WHICH, YOU
KNOW, NOT ONLY HAS THE CHALLENGE
OF BEING THE FURTHEST AWAY FROM
THE WATER TREATMENT FACILITY,
BUT TO HAVE INSUFFICIENT S